it's so strange to talk to the two of
you because you've come out here right
now and you're these very attractive
young women and I've been watching pen15
and I don't know if you feel the same
way Andy but they're on Rona I know
you're grownups and on the show the two
of you so convincingly play these
thirteen-year-old girls yeah it's
absolutely crazy what it looks like you
transform yourselves you go to great
lengths to become 13 year olds your
acting's brilliant but also just you're
able to inhabit it's like you change
your body somehow I don't know how you
do it I there wasn't that much to like
strap back exactly yeah huge breasts
that we need to strap down but that was
part of it right we also you know like I
normally have a bit of a mustache and so
I asked to just add more hairs to
exaggerate it but you know I have done
the same thing we would constantly ask
them to like keep adding more hairs keep
adding more you know eyebrow hairs to
Anna but Anna and I would genuinely look
at each other and be like I think we
look too hot it would be like a little
bit better and look in the mirror and be
like okay sooo hot and then people would
be like no no you're good it's your
haircut on the show is this bowl haircut
I think we can put it up here we have a
photograph of it this is this the real
haircut and also you know that's the
expression you have most of the time on
this show it's so captures that age what
is it explain that the bull haircut was
that something you really had it that it
have an exact bull cut but I had like a
boy but cut um that matched my grandma's
and I was called young sir a lot so
people often thought you were a boy yes
they thought I was a boy just because I
had you know like I had a butt cut and
it was parted in the middle and I had
it's called a butt cut is that what it's
called parted in the middle you know
like a butt so it's kind of like a butt
crack and then oh thank you sorry yeah I
got that part
you mean like the buttocks the way it
separates in the middle you know so
there's a space for the anus I know what
you're talking about you to have I know
you take acting very seriously because
you're both very good at it but I'm sure
you know you are you really you're
you're very good actors and you're able
to really inhabit these characters
you've changed I swear to God you've
changed your posture or something you've
had to alter your posture in order to be
these girls isn't that true can you show
me like what you're doing
like I know that you're just yeah you
cuz you're taller so you would like
thank you it was just like yeah and I'm
John Hyde what breasts you don't have
the like nipples like you would grow
nipples before breasts it's like not a
lot you're just so you're always
clinging together
[Laughter]
it's so it's funny because I say watch
that happen I'm like okay I see how you
that's another thing too is the two of
you you cling to each other in because
you're best friends and in the first
episode of the season it's the beginning
of the year and you cling to each other
for life yeah cuz and I I can relate to
that cuz every everyone else is so scary
school is so scary the world is scary
and you have each other which is yeah
holding and hiding yeah comfortable with
like this between us cuz even now like
we still you just never leave that age
you never really leave there yeah and we
still hold on to each other yeah and if
you were lucky enough at that age to
have to feel like a reject and have a
friend that was like a safety blanket
you can get through it but I think
without that I would have been screwed